otros sin brand kan aseguró que su
salida fue orquestada por estados unidos
y ahora la llegada de se basa de sharif
al poder representa más cercanía con
washington donde deja esto las denuncias
de kan
yo creo que lo que hace es sacar de
alguna manera el balón hacia afuera
porque su permanencia en el poder o no
permanencia en el poder dependía no de
una potencia extranjera sino del deseo
de quien realmente gobierna pakistán y
esas son las fuerzas militares
miren la guerra en ucrania impactó de
alguna manera en su opinión 9 para el
cambio de dirección política en pakistán
recordemos que la república islámica es
el único país es musulmán con un arma
atómica y sigamos hablando pues de las
fuerzas militares
sin duda y como bien dijo the economist
hace unos años se trata del país más
peligroso del mundo en este caso la
guerra en sí tuvo menos influencia que
la crisis enorme económica que está
sufriendo el país pero tengamos en
cuenta que el radicalismo islámico tiene
mucha fuerza tanto entre los militares
pero especialmente los servicios de
inteligencia la caída de los militares
laicos o de fuerzas laicos de pakistán
puede poner en manos de radicales
islámicos una bomba nuclear
y se va a ser y representa una cuarta
ronda de un linaje familiar en el poder
después de tres periodos periodos de su
hermano mayor como primer ministro qué
efecto tendrá de esa élite política en
el país en crisis
quizás gracias a su estirpe y su nombre
familiar pueda mantenerse en el poder
algunos días o algunos meses más si un
enorme jugador de críquet no logró
mantenerse en el poder debido a los
problemas económicos no creo que de
estirpe de un gran líder por más que
pertenezca a equis familia si no logra
solucionar los problemas económicos del
país no creo que los militares le
permitan seguir en el poder
bueno pero usted cree que el hecho de
que llegue lleva a sheriff al poder es
si representa más cercanía con eeuu y
por ejemplo con la unión europea eso de
cara de hacer un cambio de balanza
geopolítica cuando se vivía una guerra
en europa del este
si podría ser pero tengamos en cuenta
que muchos de los movimientos
internacionales de pakistán están
ligados a dos temas afganistán y
esencialmente a india recordemos que
cuando el gobierno de pakistán apoyó a
radicales islámicos era entre otras
cosas para que no se genere una alianza
con india entonces yo no creo que la
importancia fundamental que le da a los
militares sea al área internacional sino
esencialmente a sus conflictos
regionales con los dos países acabo de
nombrar